Instructor: Let's
take a look at some more spread
examples. One use case for a
spread is an alternative to
array.from, which we learned
about a couple of videos ago.
Let's say we want to select all
of these people right here.
Let's say cons people = document.
querySelectorAll, and we want to
select the .people paragraphs.
Console.log the people, and
we'll see what we're dealing
with here. We got all of our
three. You know that it's a
NodeList. But if I wanted to
call map against people, again,
we were doing something like
const names = people.map, you
know that we aren't able to do
that. Why? Because people.map is
not an actual function. If we
console.log people here, it's a
NodeList, and the prototype
doesn't have our .map or .
reducer or any of our arrays.
You could do this, array.from,
and that would then give us...
see how it's a NodeList? Refresh,
now it is a true array where our
map is located there for us.
Quite honestly, I think that I
prefer array.from, just because
it reads a little bit nicer. But
another way you could do it is
you could immediately take every
single item that it selects, and
spread it right onto an array.
That's going to take everything
that it selects. Why? Because a
NodeList is an iterable, and
every single item from that
iterable can then be spread onto
this new array. Then you see
that we have a proper array here
too. It's really up to you
what you like to use. If you're
probably on a team, array.from
probably reads a little bit
nicer. But I have seen people do
it the other way, and that would
give us our map function as we
like it. We've got one error
here, undefined is not a
function. I have to run person...
I want to return the person.
text content.
Then we should have a
names array of every single name.
Good, I'm happy with that.
Couple other examples is when
you want to create a new array
off of a property on an object.
This is similar where we merged
two arrays together. Maybe
we did const shopping list
equals a new array. We know we
have to get milk to make the
pizza, we know we have to get
flour. But we also know that
since tonight is deep dish pizza
night, we have to get all of the
ingredients from it. What I
can do is just immediately
spread all of the ingredients
from deep dish.ingredients.
Since that's an array, it's
going to take every single item
from that and put it into the
new shopping list. If I console.
log shopping list, you see that
we now have every single item in
it. That is a true copy, not a
reference to the deep dish.
This is an example where I've
run into a couple times.
Specifically I do it a lot in
reactor when using Redux. It's
when you have an array of
objects and you need to remove
one of those objects from the
actual array, and all you're
given is...This is a mean
comment, so I want to delete, "
You are so dumb." All you're
given is an ID variable with
that post ID inside of it. How
do you actually take it away?
First of all, we need to figure
out where in this array is this
comment? Because the ID doesn't
tell us anything about its
location inside the array.
How would we do that? We would
use the .find index method of
the array. We'll say, const
comment index = comments.
findIndex, and it's going to
give us a comment. We're going
to return if the comment.ID is
equal to the ID variable.
When the comment ID is equal to
the ID variable we have set here,
then return. That's going to
tell us where the index is.
Let's console.log the comment
index, see where it tells us.
Good, it tells me the index is
two; one, zero, one, two, "You
are so dumb." That's the one
I want. Now how do I actually
delete it from there? Previously,
what we had to do is slice
everything before, slice
everything after. What we
can do here is we will make a
new comment variable. We'll say
const new comments equals...and
we are going to create an array
of the new comments. We want
everything up until the mean
comment, and everything after
the mean comment. What we can do
is slice from the start to where
we want, and then slice from one
after the one that we want, to
the end. We'll say, comments.
slice. We're going to start at
zero and go until we hit the
comment index. Then I'm going to
go comments.slice. We're going
to start at the comment index
plus one. It's going to tell us
two, so we're going to start at
three. Then, we don't have to
pass the second variable because
that will just go to the end of
the comments. Even if I had 10
more comments, it would go to
the end of it. This isn't
going to totally work and I'll
show you why. Let's console.log
the new comments. What do we
have here? We have an array of
arrays, which is the first part
and the second part. That's not
very useful because you don't
want an array of arrays. You
want an array of comment objects.
What we can do is just spread
these two and spread this one,
and that will take every item
out of the array and put it into
this new comment array right
here. Now when I refresh it,
you'll see this is our new
comments array, that you have
the new comments, and we've
excluded that mean comment that
we have sliced on out. Then
you would probably take this new
comment and you would set it to
this, .set state and comments.
If you're doing something like
react, you can pass the new
comments and it's going to
update your new state without
mutating the past state.